hi I'm Hannah I'm your friendly
neighborhood wine mom and I don't
remember why hi I'm Hannah I'm your
friendly neighborhood wine mom and if
you're anything like me you believe that
a glass of wine at 9:00 p.m. makes you a
better mom so pour yourself a glass and
let's talk but first here's why I'm
drinking tonight we were at my friend's
one-year-old son's birthday party last
weekend and my four old son Jackson has
just decided that he's not going to
point with this finger anymore I don't
understand why he's four he's been
pointing like this his whole life anyway
he goes up to the one year old mom goes
hey is no one holding it up the mom is
just like ah so cheers rose 8:00 tonight
because this is a birthday present from
my mom and while we're on the topic of
birthdays let's talk about the best and
worst things of kids birthday parties
about kids birthday parties disclaimer
there is not a lot of good let's start
this on a positive note with some two
really easy pros he's intake who doesn't
love going to a kid's birthday party and
just being able to wolf down some greasy
pizza chasing it with some like awful
ingredient cake and I'm not talking
about those artisan like beet colored
prune sweetened cakes I'm talking like
the sheet cake from the grocery store
like pump that dye in there my mouth
isn't blue at the end you haven't done
your job but on the other hand there are
some parents I don't know what kind of
hell they crawled up from okay I
probably shouldn't say that they serve
salad for the parents what possesses
them to do this I'm not a rabbit
attending your party I want the same
greasy cheese bread as these children I
want to shove my face full of carbs and
fat I don't want leaves and nuts and
berries and [ __ ] pro tip if you the pro
tip put a billion pieces of pizza on
your kids plate because you know
eventually after the third piece they're
going to be like
I can't and then when they can't finish
it be like oh I don't want to waste it
and then you don't have to be stuck with
your wimpy salad I'm thinking this kind
of fast
next alcohol there are some parents
probably the same parents who serve
salad to the other parents who don't
serve booze at their party why are you
doing this to me I didn't come here to
drink some soda with you guys I came
here to have a couple of chunks of wine
and then even worse if they don't serve
soda because they don't want their kids
to accidentally open a coke Cola and
bounce off the [ __ ] ceiling you're
stuck drinking a juice box so I'm
standing in the corner talking Martha
about redoing her lawn and at least if I
had a glass of wine in my hand I could
pretend to care a little bit more I'm
out
this Rosie is really good the dangers of
Rosie is it tastes really good and it
goes down really fast
I like write a line on the bottle when
it's time to stop next is other people's
kids your kid might be awesome like both
my kids are awesome when I'm totally not
even biased I'll be the first to say
their total buds but they're awesome but
when we're at a party we also have to
deal with everyone else's crappy kid
there's always one giant kid in the
bounce house and their parents are never
there watching them they're always off
in the corner rambling to someone about
their kitchen remodel or something in
the meantime their old big child is
traumatizing all these two-year-old by
like bouncing super big and like making
the wall fly off the walls and it's
awkward to try to like tell off this
nine-year-old hey can you not be an
[ __ ] the other hand it makes you
realize that those kids might be shitty
not shitty as I thought my kids were
wait
you got that reversing their shitty but
not as shitty as a thought my kids were
what am I supposed to say huh I will get
this
sometimes I'll admit I think my kids are
totally shitty but at least they're not
a shitty of these other kids about this
party next something right I'm doing
okay I need to slow down on the line
alone okay and finally hosting there is
so much pressure when you're hosting a
birthday party
to one-up the last persons party to go
on Pinterest and find everything that
you can make yourself if it's not
handmade it's suddenly not as good my
attitude is to go to the 99-cent store
and buy it and save some time like it's
more like to please the parents which
really doesn't make any sense I've never
been satisfied from one of my children's
birthday parties I've always ended the
birthday party thinking that was a
disaster that was awful and then I look
at my child they don't care if their
cupcake tier was made by hand they don't
care if they're party favors were
handmade there's just so much joy coming
from their face just like nothing but
pure joy and that makes it completely
worth it so that's all I got for today
I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wide mom we have another kid's birthday
party to attend tomorrow of course I
have it wrap the gift of course so I'm
going to turn this nice chair into a
comfy bed and pass right out with my
last two sips of wine until next time
I don't know why they gurgle every time
you come out